when we get tomorrow's we need to solve
our basic needs in particular protection
from radiation the first crew that lands
on Mars will live in their ship but you
can't live there very long the cosmic
radiation and the solar radiation is
going to penetrate the ship you have to
get underground quickly we now know
there are certain regions on Mars that
have an extensive underground network of
lava tubes this is where the volcanoes
have existed for hundreds of millions of
years and as they died away they
actually become huge rooms when we think
about them in terms of human exploration
they could be an attractive place to
consider they provide a structure that
is radiation for your in the huge
underground cavern you still have to
have airtight holes and stuff like that
it's not like it'll hold the air in but
it'll protect you from radiation and it
also protect you from temperature
extremes the trick is lava tubes are not
so easy to find because they're
underground we're still in the process
of figuring out where those are and
mapping them is not a trivial thing now
we'd also want to create some other
kinds of living spaces outside of the
lab tubes for instance we want to have
inflatable transparent domes lit by
natural sunlight and we can grow plants
from my perspective before any humans
get to the surface of Mars we were gonna
have sent in advance habitation with
radiation shelters you won't use an
astronaut to do something as
quote-unquote menial as
building a habitat final precursors will
be an army of robots and they'll begin
to build habitats I think about the
technology we're developing today in 3d
printing imagine being able to send a 3d
print of the Martian surface that pulls
the soil out add some water add some
binder and is sitting there our 3d
printing shelters and you've got your
home's pre-built waiting for you right
there now until such time in the rather
distant future that Mars is terraformed
Mars will have a thin atmosphere and so
these things will have to be pressurized
and as a result they can't be that big
they won't be miles in diameter like the
domes you see in science fiction but
domes 50 meters a hundred meters in
diameter these are entirely possible we
will have to live in domed cities and
land spacesuits on Mars you know for a
long time but that's enough to say that
we can't have a really nice life but
it's not going to be an earth life it's
going to be Mars life